يبكون يبكيني بريكوجين وقاده من فاجنر في
طقوس قد يصح وصفها بجنازه غير رسميه في
مدينه
ويؤدون التحيه لرجل يعتبره كثيرون في
روسيا بطلا قويا رغم انه شخصيه مختلف
عليها كل شيء بدا مساء الاربعاء او
الطائره المدنيه في شمال موسكو فتغيرت
ديناميكيات كثيره ليس في روسيا فقط قد
ترددات تسمع وراء الحدود بجوجن لم يكن
مجرد شخصيه عسكريه عابره ينسب لنفسه وقوته
الفضل في حسم واحده من اطول معارك الحرب
في اوكرانيا بخموت وهو ما اكده الرئيس
الروسي في تعزيه عائله الرجل ثم دخلت
فاجنر بمدرعاتها الاراضي الروسيه وتوجهت
نحو موسكو فاختلف بتصنيف اف جيني بروغوجوش
بين من يراه بطلا قوميا ومن يصفه بخائن
العهد مع الدوله الروسيه
جدل لن يحسن لكن الصور الاتيه من المدينه
التي احتضنت مقر باجنر يمكن ان تقول انه
بالنسبه لهؤلاء لا جدل بشان من يكون يبكي